do you think you guys uh have stayed on
top and and stayed relevant because
you practice so much like like you don't
just get together and go on tour and say
[ __ ] it we played it so many times i'm
gonna
i would maybe almost say the opposite i
mean in all in all silliness
i think a part of the reason we're still
together is because we're not
so rigid that we don't let the human
element be a big part of what we do
and we don't take ourselves so seriously
that everything has to be no
[ __ ] perfect all the time and often
you know when we play if we [ __ ]
something up we'll stop and start it
over
and we get a little bit of grief in the
metal community actually
from the critics and some of the other
bands about you know metallica a little
more kind of on the sloppy side and
we kind of wear that with pride actually
you don't want it to be
road yeah and we're lazy i think we
don't want it
there's i think there's a punk rock
attitude to it also where
it's got to be fun all of us grew up on
a big part of punk aesthetics
and we also loved you know garage rock
and you know what was coming out of
detroit in the late 60s the stooges and
the mc5 and
you know bands like motorhead obviously
early ac dc and so on which is
really more about a vibe did you dig the
ramones were they were they
uh big with you yeah yeah oh yeah huge
hormones yeah their stuff
from the very beginning forgot the first
album right when it came out and it was
like
wow look at these guys i remember
showing all my friends the album cover
in 1976 he was like look at these dudes
black and white
queens dudes and their tattered jeans
and their
leather jackets was so [ __ ] cool it
was so inspiring to see the ramones
especially as a teenager because i
didn't look like robert plant
i looked more like d.d ramon
we got to play with them
yeah yeah that was such a treat and
those guys would fight all the time too
i mean they did not get along at all i
mean you must have seen some crazy stuff
with those
guys never got along howard at the very
beginning
they were [ __ ] sweethearts all of
them i used to have them on the show and
try to unite them and like and get them
talking to one another it was crazy
radio
it was just so great do you guys ever
look at like the rolling stones and
think hey maybe musically we'll all
still be together in 2015.
could you guys see yourselves at almost
80 years old still doing this
i can i think i mean if the knees and
the elbows and the necks and
the throats and all the rest of it hold
up i think definitely in the spirit of
it
definitely still be there maybe it'll be
20 versions of all within my hands at
that time rather than 20 versions of
battery or
damage incorporated or whatever but i
think that
i think spiritually and certainly
aesthetically there's a good shot